[Music]
All right, this one struck me as odd,
especially on a day like this. Saudi
Arabia's top Muslim cleric is calling
Twitter, and I quote here, a source of
all evil, saying it's full of lies. At
first, I thought, is this another Fox
attack from the left? I didn't know. No,
talking about Twitter. And and and this
on a day we're seeing this release video
of a woman being stoned to death. And
one of those stoning her, her dad.
Okay. Uh, and Twitter is the problem to
Jihad Watch director Robert Spencer.
Robert, wow. What do you think?
Well, you know, Neil, it's actually
completely consistent on the part of the
MUI of Saudi Arabia, Abdul Aziz. Uh,
what he's saying is that he's completely
in favor of things like stoning and
beheading and those kinds of things.
They're in Islamic law. Muhammad
practiced them. There's no way that the
MUI of Saudi Arabia is going to go out
on a limb and object to that. But what
he objects to is the word getting out
that these things are being done because
in his words that slanders Islam. In
Islamic law, slander is not telling lies
about somebody else. It's telling truths
about them that they don't want known.
And so that's what bothers him about
Twitter. He he he doesn't feel it's in
the least disproportionate for him to be
upset about Twitter instead of about the
stoning to death of a woman by her own
father because the stoning is Islamic
law. But it should all be kept under the
cover of darkness not talked about. I
guess what will surprise most folks is
how such diads ISIS more to the point
are able to recruit women like these
three young uh American females when you
think that if they see these other I
don't want to be there.
Yeah, absolutely. But uh the the appeal
that the Islamic State has for young
people in the west, young Muslims in the
west, is that it claims to be the
restoration of the caliphate. There has
not been sufficient discussion, Neil, of
how extraordinarily potent this idea is
among many Muslims worldwide. And we
never saw this kind of recruitment of
Muslims in the West by al-Qaeda, by
al-Shabaab, by other jihad groups. But
the Islamic State has this. They're able
to hold out that they are the ideal
place for a Muslim to live. And that's
just as appealing to young Muslim women
as it is to many young Muslim men.
Um, is this why you don't see much
criticism out of the mainstream if there
such a thing Muslim community or to
attack these extreme uh measures that
are taken or is it just you know we
don't talk about it kind of a deal?
Yeah. Well, you know, uh to be sure,
there have been condemnations of the
Islamic State from the Hamas linked
Council on American Islamic Relations
and other major Muslim groups, but what
they're not doing is do having any kind
of organized program to teach young
Muslims why they should reject this
understanding of Islam. So, you know,
you have the convert to Islam the other
day who did the hit-and- run attack on
the Canadian soldiers in Canada before
the gun the the gunshots, the uh the
gunfire attack today. and uh this
convert to Islam, nobody's asking, well,
where did he learn about this? Why
didn't the mosque where he went to
convert teach him that this was the
wrong understanding of Islam if they
really reject it? And yet, there is no
such program in any mosque in the United
States, Canada, or anywhere else.
Scary stuff. Um, thank you very very
much for joining us. We we very much
appreciate it, Robert. Um, as Robert was
speaking, we're we're hearing a little